[Applaudissements]
j'espère juste que les autres
déguisements seront mieux
ça va déguisement oui je suis une petite
tournée sur la french riviera tout l'été
j'ai pas la crêperie la paillote à
cogolin voilà toutes les dates sont sur
mon site web bartois de palabres
[Applaudissements]
artois merci on a maintenant angel
mondiale qui nous fait l'honneur d'être
avec nous ce soir mais c'est angel
hydroalcoolique
c'est presque angèle mais qui est pro
vaccin c'est parti
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
merci merci
or pour l'instant les déguisements c'est
pas ou non plus merci géraldine vois ça
change pas d'habitude non mais c'est
vrai que c'est pas ouf non plus à
ya maintenant david peta c'est comme
c'est comme david guetta mais il vient
il vient pour ce pétard en fait regardez
il est là c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
hop et à chaque fois on fait ça une fois
c'est que ça te va très bien entre r ça
te gêne
mais plus tard mesure d'aller à la can
de toit du monde est mon cas
ça va partir de là
tu vois dans mes c'est que ça doit bien
ça va bien on aime ça ça va repartir de
l'acheter alors hélas non et ça lui va
bien et les chics comme ça mais je te
jure en fait tu es champion frère parce
que je trouve de quoi tu t'es trouver du
trou mais que kwame d'aimer les verts
veut m'aider au niveau style est en
train de s'endormir ah ouais cet été à
mykonos ça tu vas faire très mal comme
toi pour le voir déjà non maîtrisée
david pts hamas mais mais tu t'es planté
tech en mai d'un deux minutes pourquoi
tu fais ça je
voudrais
ne manquez pas la dernière s'est montré
plein bénévoles avec à bertrand deckers
incroyable samedi elle s'arrête à un
truc de fou que c'est vrai mais tu l'as
vu ça mais c'est tout le gars c'est pas
tout mais je suis producteur d'émissions
on s'embrasse
il a hélas à fedpol non même s'il venait
à sept jours car la sienne non mais tu
contraintes toujours jeu contrainte et
sans doute fait autre chose c'est pour
ça rien
non non j'ai toujours pensé -
là tu l'as pas blessé et voilà
une série pas le bas et gens qui
travaillent pas le mal de toi qui fais
beaucoup de sport ouais te jure que
c'est vrai quoi je ne rigole pas ce
matin j'étais en entraînement et je te
jure qu'il aurait dit moi c'était déjà
arrivé j'ai vraiment une douleur et je
te jure que c'est vrai ici bien sûr
alors sans rigoler c'est vrai non je te
le jure que c'est vrai qu'ici je vais
essayer des choses comme ça tu vois j'ai
mal là vraiment là où exactement rue
entre aux alentours de la nuit entre les
lignes mais là j'ai tous mes yeux je te
le jure que c'est vrai est-ce que c'est
quoi ça je te jure que j'ai mal vraiment
mal là c'est rien cncd à ckoi c'est un
léger déclin à la déchire mans annales
certainement tu peux te déchirer un
allemand là le statut de best tu te bête
tu fais déjà statué c'est un muscle un
cétacé un homme tous les autres tu
comprends votre chauffe et il a dû être
pris à trois qu'est ce qu'il faut faire
alors ce qui vaut faire des gestes et on
peut bosquet non mais tu sais que je te
le jure que j'aime et j'ai toujours que
c'est vrai je te jure que c'est pas une
bonne mais je te jure que ça j'ai très
peu de muscle disait quoi j'étais en
plein jeu temps plein tournoi ouais mais
hélas je sentis vraiment là et là j'ai
dit aux gars qu'est ce qu'il faut faire
j'ai voulu rappeler parce que j'ai j'ai
gym j'ai cherché le numéro d'assuré
s'annulent
mais parce que ces nouvelles s'ils nous
avaient manqué médecin mais surtout
quand on est connu alors non mais qu'est
ce non mais sans déconner alors est-ce
que c'est arrivé parce que c'est grave
mais je te jure que ça arrive juste que
les autres ne disent pas alors une fois
l anus et un muscle non comme tous les
muscles bah tu peux avoir un ligament tu
peux avoir tu peux avoir un tennis elbow
c'est un anus elbow donc voilà donc ce
qu'il faut faire c'est me tue une petite
crème anti inflammatoires comme sainte
olle alors je peux te montrer la
première fois et tu m'as tu m'as sne
amène à 2,3 fois tu m'as de trois fois
ils sont inutilisés plus est partie au
top comme ceux ci un bon absolument
entre mois bon ben hadj imagine imagine
ça devient gênant même du matin imagine
il me dit sérieux la cer anus
alors années al nahyan anus alors c'est
pendant 7 à glace tu te retournes msa
voilà tu te retournes la fumée deux
doigts tu viens positionner tu mets la
crème juste au bas de l'année si c'est
amanda knox est question sur ses pas la
nuit c'est juste là à du change tout le
temps mais là bas si c'est la lenteur
mange rien ces voiles endroit attention
[Applaudissements]
ce que c'est la fin d'année on n'en sait
absolument c'est la fin tu m'as tu m'as
tu me c'est la fin de la nuit se dire
c'est la saint sylvestre quoi faire
pour de vrai tu n'utilises cette partie
que pour vraiment ce qui est
indispensable et question vers séropos
repos open annonce pendant au moins
trois jours et la crème de la crème de
la crème mais c'est vrai que c'est
comment tu fais quant à elle à un tennis
elbow bas de jeter 10 rennes à michel
baud bâtard est d'utiliser l'anus cette
année michel baud elle bosse à un coude
bah quoi bah oui mais là alors une
tendinite est alors il ya une unité j'ai
annulé une perte subite
7 passes et rabin tu connaisses
maupassant rigoler oui bien sûr mais je
pense que c'est parce que vous faites
beaucoup de sport en ce moment vous avez
dû augmenter vos cadence vous devez
faire beaucoup de foncier et je pense
que le corps vous dit stop il faut faire
attention les yeux dans les yeux on peut
nous dire tune à utiliser pour rien
d'autre
là je suis médecin
senna
y est vraiment déchaîné devant moi j'ai
envoyé un fax et noir avaient voté
transit ya pas de problème en aucun
problème à d'hémorroïdes rien alors je
les ai sentis j'étais en train de jouer
serré j'ai sauté comme ça tu voyais la
question déchirure 515 je sens qu'il
annule ce qui claquent et c'est petit
claquage c'est ce qui est arrivé à
beaucoup c'est ce que nadal va pas le
dire un toi tu as le temps de le dire
devant la caméra c'est vrai qu'ils ne
disent pas mais ça leur arrive donc
certains faits de bois nadal n'a pas
fait de boire était quelque chose de
c'est quelque chose qui arrive aux
sportifs de haut niveau et ça c'est
grave il faut maintenant ça serait juste
un peu d'europe pour je me repose
jusqu'à lundi à malgir et une petite
semaine non c'est pas parce que j'avais
la démission annoncée en juin j'ai je
pars en espagne vendredi agroton matt
madden
highway mais peut-être format mais pour
m tanus c'est relou
assainissement peut-être à la presse en
plus tu imagines en espagne a fait le
français est kamal al hanousse
bien qu en parle et je vais te dire en
parler c'est déjà 50% de la guérison
c'est très bien c'est comme l'alcoolisme
faut parler de ces choses à sa manière
mais seul mathieu mathieu sans rire
merci d'être là parce que j'étais
inquiet sur java mieux du coup là
d'abord par là je pense que je vais
passer la nuit sur rubis lice à thé bon
ça allait passer maintenant à peu
slimane à ces comme slimane mais on peut
se lit c'est benjamin khatchik ah oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je te jure que ça lui va bien je me suis
je me suis même équipe qui va bien et
excuse moi qui est ami donc j'ai mis un
peu de
voir ses lois ses prêts mec ça mais les
spots ami emile perez khatami les
prothèses le maersk et ami jan prothèse
parce que vous me ça y est sur mozilla
me complexe et nimani j'ai bien cru que
ça fasse plus gros un médecin dès qu on
avait très vite deux pour autant arrêter
une paire de chaussettes
qui nous reste et a mis ton récit prénom
c'est vrai d'accord banque éthique le
boni de van persie toujours qu'il est
mal sur cette viper bien vu mais
t'inquiète aimerait botter une tête
abonnés les variantes et d'amuser les
gens mais est-ce qu'on me voit mieux les
yeux le pêchent toujours mais oui en
fait oui en fait c'est ce que c'est mais
c'est en fait tu viens de remarquer
bastos et où l'autre ton visage qui
arriva
mais en fait je te jure que si tu te
raser la tête ça fait maintenant le fait
maintenant
[Applaudissements]
on
l'espère pour la sarako super la mode à
dieu dit l'élu tu aimerais tu vas être
beaucoup plus beau je te dis écoute-moi
frais à ce que je t'ai envoyé sur un pic
oui non oui bah oui c'est déjà arrivé
quand même très rose fais moi confiance
en eux et bonne raison que non mais
je donne un conseil ouais maintenant à
cause des vis ta vie ouais et arrête de
vivre celle de ta femme voilà je te le
demande comment un service mareg la vie
c'est à vie la vie de ta femme c'est la
vie de papa est ce que ta femme quand
elle se coupe les cheveux et appels non
non c'est toi et ben voilà il va
t'asseoir quand c'est
pas mal je te jure je te dire que tu es
très beau comme ça bail que je vais me
couper les cheveux je ne rigole pas et
le faire le fais avec grand plaisir les
shihri maintenant on à shakira ou c'est
à dire c'est un professeur raoul chez
la cousine ou accompagné de son ex mari
gérard paquet c'est presque gerard piqué
sûr qu'il a un très gros pack et voilà
c'est pas ou feint
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dames
m
m il a
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
photo
oui
[Musique]
m gera
alors alors shakira ou très bien gérard
piqué des boues tout le monde mais
vraiment vraiment vraiment je vais
m'asseoir et ils dansent pas mal à les
grands moments c'est kelly clé m'inspire
à chaque fois donc c'est kelly d'anciens
comme avec évidence mieux que shakira
ouais c'est vrai on a eu la preuve c'est
vrai et cette perruque voix très très
bien vraiment ça va bien catherine lara
c'est vrai ce héros d'hier et catherine
là on a envie de passer nulle magie
catherine lara qui embrasse que j'adore
ah oui je suis fou de catherine lara qui
est venu nous voir un jour j'étais très
content alors vous êtes au courant pour
mon anus
j'ai suivi ça de près non mais vous avez
que j'ai vraiment je pense sincèrement
comme géraldine c'est un gros claquage
du trou de balle
tu fais ça tu vois oui oui toi c'est çà
et là j'ai entendu chez crack avait
entendu en plus c'est pas entendu mais
j'ai senti un choc cette époque la
première fois que vous avez touché
depuis non je veux toucher aidé à
gonfler mais voyez vraiment tu vas être
comme ça dans la rue en train de toucher
mon annuler pour sentir justement si un
petit hématome si c'est un peu gonflé si
c'est un peu chaud non non non non non
je fais cela pour toutes les personnes
qui nous écoutent quand vous êtes sous
votre douche un petit toucher rectal
c'est
alors calmez vous arrêtez ça va tu
oublieras ça va très bien
quand tu as tout est folle non mais
vraiment at t est incroyable vraiment
c'est fou allez on a maintenant les
dibaba c'est presque lady gaga sauf
qu'elle est de la même famille qu'un
animateur de ces
partis
alors
[Applaudissements]
salut
t on croit qu'on son anus
[Rires]
je t'aime à tokyo et hong kong mon anus
merci béatrice arabe est un homme ya ça
m a marqué ma seigneur et je suis très
inspirée par un grand d'ancien français
qui s'appelle bob à moi je veux pas
d'enfant parce que j'ai mal à la nage
comment vous dire merci merci à
christian
bale
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai merci merci les chalets est
pas mal on
va tuer maintenant rabhi mercury
c'est presque freddie mercury sûr qu'il
anime des bar mitsva il est là c'est
parti
[Applaudissements]
mais
je peux pas voir ça
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
il ressemble un petit mécanisme
les mercury après dix bonnes j'ai traîné
non mais non mais je ne cautionnerai
non métro mettez le son quand même parce
que la force
[Applaudissements]
je vais regarder si je peux danser en
ayant mal à l'anus
réclamer davantage
[Applaudissements]
c'est bon ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la tendance
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ga
ouah
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
j'ai joué je reviens des latéraux
malheureusement j'ai pas là l'anus s'est
pas contenté de 6
et ben saada
envie de le revoir
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
bien qu on va la refaire sans les
chiffrer mais
tu te mets là il arrive vous avez à
mykonos
la rentrée des 6 nations tu vois que tu
m'aimes prédit toi tu arrives dollars
tarim emboîtera j'arrive en boîtes de
[Rires]
500 points de nichols mrc sens quel
point j mais
il a décidé de s'habiller comme freddie
mercury il arrive à la boîte l'oromo le
rambo ap c'est vraiment beau deuxième
étage le deuxième étage a bien entendu
quand on ne rentre pas exactement oui
c'est vrai ah ben c'est bon c'est qu'on
dit faut pas y aller si on a si tu y vas
t'en sors tu en as mon problème
oui c'est assez embêtant il faut pas
grand-chose à faire je vais chercher
en gros deux ibao rambo 2 là je vois
freddy arriver tu te vois alors sache
que d'habitude il travaille à la
boulangerie
[Rires]
la boulangerie juste à côté voilà donc
ils arrivent ils n'ont rambouillet ouais
la connaissez voilà et trans est parti
il va danser comme un pouvoir c'est
qu'ils sont premiers
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
toute l'année on va déjà laurent
beauvais c'est comme ça que ça se passe
mathieu parce qu'ils voient là un petit
peu jazzy de 17 ans elle chérit allez-y
alors vous pouvez vous parler je vais
faire les séries j'ai un gros problème
quoi qu'elle en a oublié daniel
mettez moi du peu de musique les chéris
s'il vous plaît c'était moi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
téléphoner
mais ça
n'avait pas eu mal quand vous avez fait
ça comment a t-on à nu je lui avais pas
joué avec non non non non mon anus n'ai
pas touché à prendre celui de raymond
vraiment eu les larmes aux yeux raymond
de 10 selon le monde le diplôme les
chiffres d'avant milliers de personnes
c'est vrai j'avais blé valérie
s'est dit naim dans st bées non c'est
pas ça
abou ah oui c'est céline dion c'est
presque céline dion marc version berbère
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est un génie on dirait jean dujardin
dans oss
juste au dessus de 1600 morts
ça va
redescendre il a peut-être trop donné il
a peut-être des messages de ses enfants
des sms il est relié ça va non mais ça
ça crée ton manège quand même
sa part commencé avec un poney
c'est sûr que là et d'ailleurs il a
démarré près de chromite trop de tête
matalon direct c'était un peu ça va
ouais
c'est comme on dirait qu'il vient de
sauter en parachute
on peut repartir les mains martory
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
non m
bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oser
proposer n'hésite pas
je trouve il ne s'en lasse pas il prend
goût avec ces cas là si tu ne dois
jamais refaire mykonos que
vous avez les corps ne disent pas ce qui
laissera toile
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
à mon avis je pense qu'il disait à une
petite séquence qui gêne c'est qu'il est
en train de découvrir qu'il aime ça
je vous jure que c'est vrai il a la tête
du gars qui se dit ouais est-ce que j'ai
pas attendu toute
sexualité et c'est bien c'est bien c'est
pour ça que cette émission est important
qu'on gagne
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est bon tout est nettoyé écoulé 2
jusqu'à
deux jours
sur
[Rires]
un promu la voiture tu t'emmerdes à
19h09
tu appelles 19h09 si vous nous rejoignez
sachez que j'ai la nuit en fait
tu n'as faut d'ailleurs on va le mettre
on va faire un déroulant bien entendu si
vous nous rejoignez cours de cette
émission mais c'est en direct on à nu
souffre mais mon manège mon anus va s'en
sortir un
pays qui dort mieux je me soigne et
l'anus
que nicki minaj
s'est presque nicolas minaj sauf qu'elle
tolère qu'en faisant les poussières les
attentions sont les meilleurs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
bonjour
voilà
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
c'est
tout
j'espère que ça va zy alors que les
samba et saluant le 14 12
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
ardennes
ban
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non monsieur
[Applaudissements]
salut attention c'est parti
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]